When the coefficient of the highest degree term in a polynomial isn't one we
need to take some extra steps to be sure that we're factoring correctly. First
things first you should always look for a common factor between all of the
terms in the expression. So here for example we have f of x equals 10x squared
Minus 30x minus 40. This might look kind of hard to factor but if we notice
that there's a common factor that we can take out first, the rest of the
function will be much more easy to factor. So what is the greatest common
factor that is shared by all three terms on the right hand side of this
equation. Note that I'm abbreviating greatest common factor as GCF. Please
write that number in this box.